Good men do not get enough credit
so heres a list of all the green flags in men
starting off with No. 1- if he makes good eye contact
men who aren't afraid to hold eye contact with you
and you can stare into their dreamy eyes
and they reciprocate that same energy back
that is a huge green flag!
No. 2- has basic manners
he's polite he knows to say please and thank you
he's nice to others especially service worker
and he holds the door open for you
that is a true gentleman
No.3 he laughs or smiles a lot
he's generally just carefree
if he can lighten the mood with a joke or he's high energy and giggling
then that is a huge green flag
4 he ask you personal questions about yourself
it's not just surface level
it means he's genuine and he just wants to get to know you on a deeper level
No. 5- when a man doesn't rush you
when men let you live at your own pace
usually means they're chill and they go with the flow
and they know when to compromise
No. six- when he matches your energy
if you can be weird around him
and he matches that same energy back and is as equally weird
that's a huge green flag when he allows you to be yourself
and he shows his playful side with you